[Inaudible].
Hello. People who are free, at least for now. It's me,
your host, who is free at least for now.
Dave Rubin today is December 7th, 2020.
This is the Rubin report direct message.
And we're doing all locked down edition of the direct message today.
Everything that I'm doing today is about the lockdown we're putting aside the
election stuff for a little bit.
There's obviously a lot going on there and things working through the courts and
the rest of it. Uh,
but I sense something big is happening on the lockdown front. There,
there is a major,
major pushback against what's going on and I felt we should just devote the
whole show to it with a whole bunch of different clips from different cities,
different States, people fighting for their rights. I also spent this weekend,
uh, at some rallies and I just feel like people
have had it and they're pushing back.
And that really is the most American thing that you can do. Let's not forget.
I am live in Los Angeles where as of, I believe this morning or,
or like midnight last night, we are now under full, locked down.
They don't want you walking your dog. They don't want you to roller skating.
They don't want you biking. They don't want you doing pretty much anything.
They want you to sit alone and depressed and pathetic and neutered.
I refuse to do that. I've got a couple people in the room with me right now,
come and get me Garcetti, come and get me. I actually, this weekend,
not only did I go to one of the rallies, we'll,
we'll talk about that in just a second,
but because it was important that you only do vital things.
You know what I mean? Really vital things. I, uh,
yesterday morning ordered NBA jam.
Remember NBA jam from the early mid nineties, the, uh,
the amazing arcade game NBA jam. Well,
now you can get a home version of the arcade game. It's only 500 bucks.
I ordered it and picked it up at best buy,
but I felt that that was vital for me because you've got NBA jam on there.
You've got like NBA jam tournament edition, and then one other one.
And I put it together yesterday and you can play Wi-Fi and David and I beat my
brother and my 10 year old nephew.
It's like one of the first times I've been able to beat my nephew in anything.
So I'm very excited and that was what's vital for me to stay alive. Uh,
all right. So you know what,
instead of running down all the stories which I normally do at the top of the
show where we're just going to plow into them,
because they're all just one after the other lockdown related things.
So we showed you a video, Oh, you know what, real quick,
before I get into that fully, uh,
our direct message on Friday was our most watched direct message ever about
800,000 views on YouTube alone. That's not that doesn't include what's going
on@therubinreportcommunityandontheblaze.com. And I just want to say that I'm,
I'm thrilled. So many of new people, so many of you who are new are here,
uh, and obviously what we're talking about and trying to noodle through these
issues in an honest way, it matters.
And more of you guys are sharing the videos and commenting on them and all that
good stuff. So I appreciate it. I thank you.
And I'll do my best not to let you down. Okay. So, uh,
we showed a video last week.
This was a woman by the name of Angela Marsden. And she, uh,
is the owner of pineapple Hill restaurant and bar, uh,
in Sherman Oaks, California in Los Angeles in effect in the Valley.
And she showed, we showed the video,
but she basically did a selfie video of her restaurant and the fact that they
had closed her down, not only inside,
but even though she did all of this stuff to make a really nice outdoor area,
they closed her down. But then right next to that, they were allowing, um,
a movie or a TV show. I think it was a TV show, actually like a Netflix show,
set up tents for their people to eat. So those people are essential,
but apparently she's not essential. Well,
I actually went to the rally that she was at and I interviewed her.
We put up a video over the weekend about that,
but let's take a look quick at the, uh,
just like a 22nd bite of the original video. And then we'll go from there.
So this is my place, the pineapple Hill grill in saloon. If you go to my page,
you can see all the work I did for outdoor dining,
for tables being seven feet apart.
And I come in today because I'm organizing a protest and I came in to get
stuff for that. And I walk into my parking lot.
And obviously.
But sake, we're not going to show you the whole thing right now,
but we showed it all on Friday. And I interviewed her on Saturday.
So what happened was, as I said in the parking lot there, you see,
she sets her bar outside stuff. And then if you watch the end of the video,
they show you that, Oh, if you're a TV production,
you're allowed to sit outside and eat,
but they aren't as if any of this has to do with science as if any of this has
to do with anything constitutional or sensible or anything else.
So Sheila and a bunch of people, because I'm sorry, not Sheila.
Sheila's the woman we'll get to in just a minute, Angela,
because that video went so viral.
And I'd like to think that I had a little something to do with it. Uh,
they did a big rally on Saturday at the house of Sheila.
Cool. Now Sheila cool.
I had talked about last week because she was one of the five city supervisors
who voted just last week to close everything, right?
That's what allowed, uh, furor Garcetti to close everything. And in effect,
they voted three to two to close all of the restaurants. And then Sheila cool,
this woman who makes over $300,000 a year,
$300,000 a year to just be a government,
nothing to just be a middleman who controls people's lives,
who are actually producing. She voted three to two.
So she was the deciding vote to shut down all the restaurants.
And then as we talked about last week, what did she do?
She went to an outdoor restaurant,
even though she was going to close them all down in a few days,
but it was so severe what's happening with COVID. It's so dangerous.
We've got to crush all of these 1000 restaurants that we have in Los Angeles.
And so Cal, and, but she could just get one last quick Italian meal in there.
So these people are hypocrites and Angela,
and a bunch of you organized a rally at Sheila's house. Now,
I don't like doing these things at people's houses. I actually,
when I got there, I said to Angela, Oh,
I wish we would have done this at your restaurant.
I even offered her a thousand bucks. I was just going to buy people food,
but there was just too many things happening too, to do it at once.
But if she wants to do that, Angela,
I'm guessing you're probably watching now when we're texting. So, uh, uh,
that offer still stands. Um, but in any event,
they did it at Sheila cool's house.
Couple hundred people came bunch of a bunch of press was there.
We've we've got a bunch of photographs that I think were relaying in as I'm
discussing some of this stuff. And, and it was,
it was just incredible because you really need to understand that the people
that are showing up to these things,
I met several other restaurant owners and other business owners.
These are not radicals. Many of them probably two months ago.
Didn't think of themselves as trumps.
Although I think a lot of them are rethinking it right now, right?
I don't think these are particularly political people.
These are just people who want to go out and live. That's all they are.
I met a guy who owns 39 restaurants in LA employs about a thousand people.
He's had to lay off about 800 people. He now said,
he's going to run for County supervisor,
which is a cool Sheila cools job.
So people are getting involved and pushing us. It's like, you're just pushing,
pushing, pushing on good people. I don't know if we showed it already,
but we can also throw up the image of me signing the petition. Yeah, we did, uh,
of me signing the petition to recall Gavin Newsome.
And it's a very complex situation. And if your pen literally touches the line,
it doesn't count. And like a whole bunch of a whole bunch of stuff.
But I signed the petition to get rid of Newsome. Who's just a horrific,
horrific governor and our awful mayor here in New York city. And again, uh,
here in Los Angeles. And again, these are just good people.
These aren't political people. They don't want to hurt anybody.
They want to be able to live and to meet all of these people.
Who've dedicated their lives to something, to build something.
And then just watch bureaucrats, take it away,
knowing that there's no science behind it. It's, it's, uh,
I feel different actually than I felt over the last couple days.
And I was sort of more annoyed than usual last week. And this week I'm,
I'm feeling some kind of like righteous indignation.
Like we've got to fix this and no one's coming to save us guys.
No one is coming to save us.
If you think some good guys are coming and the Avengers are going to assemble,
they aren't your, the Avengers now. And you got to push back. So Eric,
our city let's throw a couple of quotes in, uh, from, uh, Mr. Mayor. He said,
my heart goes out to Ms.
Marsden and the workers at pineapple Hills saloon who have to comply with the
state and County public health restrictions that close outdoor dining,
meaning no one likes these restrictions,
but I do support them as our hospital ICU beds to capacity in cases of increased
500%, we have to stop this virus before it kills thousands of more Angelenos.
Now we showed you a chart on Friday about ICU, uh,
the amount of beds that are taken in ICU and in the regular hospitals.
And although they are now going up again,
they have never gotten close to being overwhelmed here in Los Angeles.
As far as I know,
we haven't had anywhere in the United States where its hospitals have really
been overwhelmed. That means we've done something good.
That means people do wear masks. That means, you know,
businesses are acting responsibly. And again, guys, and don't forget it.
Cause they're going to try to make you memory hole, everything.
1984 in March, we were told two weeks to flatten the curve.
Does this feel like this is about COVID anymore?
Does it feel like it's about something else? And,
and also just think about it this way.
And this is what you need to bring up when your,
when your crazy uncle or whoever is screaming at you about this stuff.
We have some States like Florida in particular,
Texas red States that are opened up. They're much more opened up.
People are doing what's responsible,
whatever they feel is right for their lives.
And then we have these States and severe lockdown like California. Now,
why are the numbers not wildly out of control? If they are, please show me.
But nobody seems to be able to show me right? If, if this is to be true,
if all of this is to be true, follow the science and all that. Well,
one state's opening up. They're letting people do what they want.
People are eating out. They're talking to each other.
They're singing during holidays. Well, shouldn't those numbers be exploding.
Not, not just a little bit higher or just comparable,
but shouldn't those numbers be exploding while these are going down.
And then if that was the case, wouldn't people from red States, Florida,
and Texas be fleeing. There's a mass outbreak of a disease.
That's killing everybody. We have no hospital beds or any of those.
Wouldn't they be fleeing to the sanctuary of blue States,
but ha ironically, that's not happening.
Obviously you all know what's happening,
which is that people in blue States are fleeing to go to red States to be
freer and live their lives and save on taxes and everything else.
So someone like, like sometimes they'll tell you to follow them science, which,
which really at this point means almost nothing.
And I watched a video this morning of Andrew Cuomo and Fowchee giggling for like
five minutes about which one of them is DeNiro in which one of them is Peshy or
something, or they're just laughing. Like, they're this fun duo now.
And it's like, you guys are all just gross.
These people are gross and this is about control.
It has almost nothing to do at this point, uh, with COVID. But all right,
I've been talking about LA in California, let's get to the other coast.
So we also talked about the story last week in Staten Island.
And I should mention that one of the things that I'm really going to try to do
with this show,
and I think we're doing a pretty decent job of it so far is that, you know,
one of the things that happens in news is you get a story and then you never
find out what else happens, right?
They just tell you something that keeps you in the initial outrage.
And that's it. I'm going to try not to do that.
So last week you all heard the story of max public house.
This is a bar in Staten Island, which is as New York as you can get. Okay.
It's just perfect quintessential New York.
And this guy wanted to keep his pub open. The police sent plain clothes,
police officers there. They shut him down. Uh, he tried to stay open.
They wouldn't, they wouldn't let him open. Uh,
well then in the last couple of days, uh, his lawyer and his, uh,
representative held a press conference right outside and, uh,
listen to some of the stuff that that Mack and his guys are going through right
now. This is video from Fox news.
The Blasio, and now Cuomo have told the people of Staten Island,
New York city and the country that if you speak up to the emperor,
you get crushed in the last week, just to give you a timeline.
Lou jell amino,
one of the finest criminal defense attorneys around and Mark Fante, um,
who represent Dan Mac max pub, uh,
Lou was served with Louis charged with a misdemeanor for trying to be a lawyer.
Our political leaders came here to try to stand up for the guys and the
restaurants and the movement.
And Andrew Lanza was nearly handcuffed in front of max pub for trying to stand
with the people. The other night,
we found out that it was a political ambush.
More details will come your way on what's happened,
but it's a tale of two cities. Walmart just announced the pain,
$700 million in bonuses and sat down.
Restaurant owners are getting arrested two times in a week for trying to make a
hundred bucks. The ignorance is so high that on national television,
they find it funny that small business owners are trying to feed their families
while the millionaire's sitting in their perch. Okay.
So I'll reference that last line in just a sec about national television and
what they're doing,
because SNL just dropped in one of their painfully unset on funny skits about,
about just that, but he said a couple of things.
So that's the representative for Mac and, uh, for the, for the pub there, uh,
that they're going after lawyers. And again,
do you think that this representative or this lawyer or Mac,
do you think that any of these people want it to be fighting the government
right now? What do you think these people want?
I think they just want to go to work.
I think they just want to feel that they have a sense of purpose and they can
make some money and they can feed their families. That's it? That's it.
Nobody wants to be in this position, not the lawyers, not the, not the owners,
not the people who want to go out and live their lives.
And we've got governments that are coming, they're coming for everybody.
And we're just sitting there doing nothing about it. And, and by the way,
you know, when this makes it to mainstream news, it's only to market.
So SNL Saturday night live, which was a funny show about 30 years ago,
I think it stopped being funny,
basically that last season that Phil Hartman was there yet that Phil Hartman,
Adam Sandler when Adam Sandler was funny season. And then, and then, uh,
Ellen Cleghorne was on back then. And, uh,
Mike Myers I think was on a couple of other guys. And then it's just been trash.
It's just left his trash now for the last, you know,
probably 25 years or something. But this is this guy, Pete Davidson.
Who's just deeply on funny, but don't take my word for it. Uh,
mocking the people who were trying to live while he has a job where I'm sure
he's making hundreds of thousands of dollars and has fame and everything else.
So this is SNL this past Saturday.
So the rule is that they're supposed to let people eat or drink outside.
And the owner said, no one wants to do that. Cause they'll go out of business.
But the argument that in Staten Island don't want to drink outside can be
disproven by going to literally any little league game.
One guy at the protests even gave a speech where he literally compared not being
able to drink indoors to being Jewish during the Holocaust,
which must've been awkward for.
The people there who had to suddenly pretend they believed in the Holocaust.
So I take it. Or you found these protests frustrating. Yeah, man,
that making us look like babies, you know, you know,
it's bad when even people in Boston are like, ah, drink at home, your quiz.
W what did I just watch there? People are paid to write that. I mean, what's,
self-righteous drivel by put on a shirt. You Dick,
like these people are awful. They're dope. See, I cursed, I cursed.
I was trying to remember what I said on Friday.
I was trying to not curse as much. Cause I was cursing a little more last week.
That was a total accident right there. But these are horrible people.
You are mocking the people who want to make a living while you make I'm sure
that guy makes six figures. There's no doubt about it.
And he's been in movies and he's loved by Hollywood. And what is comedy?
Comedy is supposed to be punching up, right? Comedy is supposed to be,
you fight something above you. You make a joke about it.
What does a gesture in a court do? Right?
You make fun of the King that makes everybody realize they're part of the thing.
These are guys. These are people that are punching down.
They're punching people who are out of work.
And what was the implication that people who want to go to these bars don't
believe in the Holocaust. What the hell are you talking about?
These people are absolutely awful.
And the reason it's worth showing you that not that anyone watches SNL besides
the, the blue check, like Twitter elites, like nobody watches it.
Nobody actually thinks it's funny, but you can feel the whole system,
the whole awful system that we've been fighting against for the last four years,
you can feel it like kind of recalibrating right now and starting to come back
where SNL will now make fun of Republicans and regular people again.
And we're going to have all of the swamp come back and all of these loser
middle-management bureaucrats who are all being let back in by Biden.
It's like the whole awful thing is trying to come back right now.
I don't know that it will come back. I hope that it doesn't come back.
And I still, I said, we're not going to really talk about the election,
but I still think there's a lot of things going on there. We shall see.
But just Pete Davidson, if you're watching this,
you're a horrible human being who is making money by making
fun of people who are hurting. That's what you're doing with your life and,
and get, get out of that hoodie and put on a shirt like you guys are just,
they're just pathetic. These people. I don't care about the hoodies.
It's not about the hoodie.
These people are just like pathetic and they're unfunny.
And they're paid to write that crap to mock decent people while decent people
want to go to work, who are the good guys and who are the bad guys.
And if you listen to mainstream, it's almost completely backwards.
I'm going to guess that Pete Davidson probably has more friends that are closer
to Holocaust deniers than anyone at that bar. Bigger out what that means.
I'm not even sure. All right, let's move on. Let's go back to this coast.
I'm just bouncing all over America. Today.
We'll have to do more in the middle of the country.
We'll have one from the Pacific Northwest in just a minute,
but I need some stuff in the middle of the country.
Can you guys send me some videos?
This is sheriff Bianco from Riverside County here in California,
who has decided that he's not going to enforce Newsome's lockdowns.
And this is what a brave public servant sounds like. Sheriff, take it away.
The dictatorial attitude toward California residents,
while dining and luxury traveling,
keeping his business open and sending his kids to in-person private schools is
very telling about his attitude toward California residents,
his feelings about the virus. And it is extremely hypocritical.
These closures and stay at home orders are flat out ridiculous.
The metrics used for closures are unbelievably faulty and are not representative
of true numbers and are disastrous for Versailles County.
When the medical field is so split about this virus,
it might be time to employ a little common sense,
keeping money and support from our hospitals who are struggling with normal
seasonal increases in patients,
coupled with COVID-19 patients is irresponsible.
It appears part of the new goal is to shift attention away from his and others'
personal behavior with a do. As I say,
not as I do attitude by turning public opinion against California sheriffs.
He is expecting us to arrest anyone, violating these orders,
cite them and take their money, close their businesses,
make them stay in their homes and take away their civil liberties.
Or he will punish all of us.
I believe that all jobs are essential to someone leaders do not
threaten attempt to intimidate or cause fear bullied.
Sheriff Bianco. If you're watching this, you are a great man.
You are a great man. And I just want to say that I,
for one and I think most good Americans, we stand with our sheriffs.
We stand with our law enforcement. I think blue lives matter.
I think most of these people, not even most,
I think 99.9% of these people are good people who go into this type
of public service to do good,
as opposed to what happens to the people that go purely into the political side,
who just want to control everybody and never produce anything.
If you're going into law enforcement, you know, your life is on the line.
Your butt is on the line every single day.
And I think these people deserve our support.
What this guy is doing is absolutely right. He says a couple things there.
He says the metrics are unbelievably faulty. Well,
of course we know that's true because it's all random.
And none of it makes sense.
I mean the most basic one that I mentioned last week is that part of our new
lockdown here in California is that museums and
zoos must be at 50% museums, virtually all indoors, zoos, outdoors,
but they just okay. 50%, each one that makes sense, 20% real, um, you know,
retail stores. It's like, they're just making up nonsense.
And we are all just going along with it because know what most people don't want
to be revolutionaries. I don't. And yet here we are,
most people want to go about living their lives, but they're literally,
they are stealing our lives like this in a weird way. Oh,
one of the people at the, at the rally on Saturday, he said to me,
one of the business owners said to me, this is a fate, worse than death.
This is a fate worse than death. And I kept thinking about that line, like,
like, think about a debt. Okay, you get shot, you get taken out. Whatever it is,
you get hit by a car like it's over, it's over.
Maybe you did something good in this world. Maybe it didn't.
Maybe you have regrets. Maybe you live like a perfect human being.
You accomplish everything you want to accomplish.
But this thing where your livelihood is being stolen from you
in this restaurant owners estimation was a fate worse than death that you
believe in something, you give your blood,
sweat and tears to something and someone who should have no power over you is
allowed to just take it away. And I don't think we,
the people are going to stand for it much longer. Right. I just don't.
He also said we need common sense. A little common sense. Yeah.
That would probably be good.
And then what I really loved is that he made the point, uh,
sheriff Bianco had made the point that this is about shifting attention.
So when Garcetti does this and he's out masculine at a rally, you know,
a couple of months ago, or Newsome's at French laundry,
these people are shifting attention from their failures. By the way,
I just read this morning that Garcetti is going to be on Joe Biden's, uh,
incoming team. Like that's going to help with the, with the January 20th event,
the inauguration event. So it's like, he'll fly here and do that.
That has nothing to do with being the LA mayor. These, these are,
they're just genuinely horrible people. You know,
one of the things that I try to do on the show,
and I think I mostly succeed on it, not just on the show,
but in life is that I try to talk about ideas more than people. So one,
you know, I'll talk about what people's thoughts are, what their actions are,
things like that as opposed to going after people.
But I do think it's different at this point with politicians,
which is why I've directly called out these people.
And I've got my fake newsman glasses. When I do it.
These people specifically must be called out.
They must be called out because they are the ones making the decisions.
I don't go after.
I try not to really go after the pundits that I disagree with or that sort of
thing. I tried to talk more about their ideas.
Obviously I'm not perfect at that. Nobody is. Um, but these are bad people.
So I just want to say, and by the way I said it, there were,
there were a group of great officers who were in Santa Monica when I was at the
rally at Sheila cool's house. And I went up to them and I thanked them. And, uh,
and a few of them knew who I was. And it's like, these are good people.
They don't want to stop anyone from living their lives. And,
and basically it's, it's we,
the people versus the small amount of loud lunatics
who want to control us and, and that's what the battle of the future is.
And not only that,
then you couple that with the reality war that I'm always talking about that
half the people don't see any of this stuff, because they're watching CNN.
So anyone in your family that doesn't watch these types of shows,
they have no idea that any of is going on and you see an end showing the
rallies, like think if you were an honest news organization,
that woman out there that's newsworthy, that's newsworthy,
but what do you get to see on mainstream?
You get to see Pete Davidson make fun of the people who want to live. And man,
this is, this is seriously dangerous. Uh, let's jump to one other video.
And then I promise if you guys send me some videos,
just tweet them at me at Rubin reporter.
It's it's best if you joined the Rubin port community.
And then I have a much better chance of seeing it.
If you see videos from the middle of the country. Cause I don't like that.
I'm just bouncing a lot between New York and LA here or New York and California.
Uh, but this is from bend Oregon and there was a rally to open up,
uh, Oregon. Right?
And that means that there are some same people still in Oregon,
without question, there are, it's just Portland, that's gone completely bananas.
Uh, but here is a woman who purports to be a teacher. She says, she's a teacher.
And she has a few choice words for some of the people that just want to go back
to work and try to live their lives.
[Inaudible].
Uh, it brings me back to third grade.
That does remind me of my third grade teacher. I mean, these,
the only reason I'm playing that video,
I don't care about this woman as a private citizen, forget about her.
But the point is, if she is a teacher,
like these are the hysterical nut bags that are teaching your children on top of
the fact that we have critical race theory being pushed back into the schools
and the rest of it.
Like there are mentally unhinged lunatics who often are,
are being pushed on us by the teacher's unions that are completely out of
control at this point that don't even want to work. And in effect,
most of them are not even the teachers aren't even working on these stupid zoom
things. I mean, I'm hearing this from so many parents, it's ridiculous. Um,
but I I'm really playing that video if it had just been some random woman
screaming, I wouldn't have played it.
But the idea that this woman is a teacher putting aside the,
she dropped a couple of F-bombs.
So even if I hadn't dropped the F bomb before the F bomb was coming in this
episode, so most likely there goes monetization that's okay. Um, anyway,
it's important to know that we're just watching so much stuff kind of
collapse right now. And I think, I think it is your job more,
more than ever before,
more than any of us could have ever realized if you live in modern times that
you've got to be one of the ones with the cool heads, you gotta be cool,
calm and collected right now and,
and know what you believe and why you believe it.
And if you want to find out some of the things that I believe you could check
out my book, cause I lay out all of this stuff.
And I was warning about all of this stuff for a long time. Um,
anyway,
this was the special lockdown edition of the Rubin report.
Direct message. Uh,
we are not going to be live tomorrow or Wednesday because I am actually
heading to DC to go to the white house. That's right.
I am going to the white house Hanukkah party, which is on Wednesday.
So I'm leaving tomorrow. Uh, I'll be there tomorrow and Wednesday.
So we won't have live shows tomorrow or Wednesday,
but I may do some live streams with the, with the trusty phone.
And I have reached out to the press team. Uh,
that's in charge of the president of the United States.
And obviously we've been going back and forth for quite some time.
I'm going to see if I can get a few minutes with him.
So maybe I can do a little live stream from the oval office or something.
We'll see if we can pull that off.
And then I'll be meeting some interesting people in DC.
So we'll probably have a bunch of content that goes up over the next two days.
Um, but we will not have an in studio show tomorrow or Wednesday.
Uh, but we will be back at 11:00 AM, Pacific 2:00 PM Eastern on Thursday.
And then of course on Friday as well. Uh, anyway,
send me some videos if you're seeing more of this stuff. And you know,
one of the things that I did in the,
in the Rubin report community this morning was I posted just like,
what are your thoughts on the world?
Because I think I can get way more, uh, incisive,
interesting pieces, little nuggets of knowledge from,
from regular folks.
Then I can buy any of the pundit class and certainly anyone on mainstream media.
And that, that does help me shape which way I should take this show.
And I could just really feel this morning that so many people are frustrated
with this lockdown. And again, that is not to diminish COVID,
but at some point you have to figure out which one is doing more damage.
Is it the lockdowns that have trapped us in our house and kept us depressed and
rates of alcoholism and everything else and people that are unemployed and
people who have nothing,
just nothing to do and don't feel any reason to wake up and everything else just
on the whims of politicians or is it the actual disease?
Think about that for yourself. And then we'd probably start having some answers.
All right, guys, that's it for today. Uh, as I said, DC, tomorrow and Wednesday,
I'll do some videos and Periscopes and a whole bunch of other stuff.
And then I'll be back in here on Thursday. All right. People.
How.